foreign
ER I met
yeah
um
that's been good lately
very good um so
we last we we talked about Crowder was
the was the Landau situation which I'm
really glad that this kind of happened
and because for for a while there was
just screaming just screaming of
screaming like these people are going to
eat each other these people [__] hate
each other Crowder is not sincere
Crowder [__] all his employees but of
course the other employees San Andreas I
couldn't say anything some of them still
under NDA Fox over his employees I'd
like to be specific yes Fox over he's
trying to get very litigious and I want
to make right right right you said [__]
employees and I I just because he's very
loyal sorry I apologize I mean [__] him
like he [__] the most we're just
looking out for each other because I'm
gonna say some [__] you're gonna have to
correct I don't know if he actually has
sex with his employees I have no inside
knowledge on that so that's not in any
way am I saying that absolutely zero
there's no we have no indicators that he
has sex with male employees we do not
believe that I'll even say this that's a
slanderously I'll even say this yeah and
I mean this I've had zero people ever
come to me and say that he has sex with
his employees not I haven't had nobody
say that to me not one
um I now it's [__] sucks because we
really actually are unironically saying
that and it's usually when we do that
it's a bit Yeah but it's not a bit it's
not a bit this time we're being 100 true
um I
we we've covered the Crowder stuff
um look man I'm gonna be honest with you
with this situation right
I don't want to sit here and [__] you
know [__] on people's relationships and
and and if people get divorced [__]
[__] everyone 50 of people get
divorced so it's whatever it's it's it's
not to many of that but it's his
reaction to it now that's my problem and
not that he's getting divorced because
[__] look dude people get divorced right
but
what bugs me about this is that
everything leading up to it is the
reason he's been such a [__] [__] to
land down such a [__] [__] to others
other producers and knock it Jared Sven
all these other people and even quarter
black Air I don't have any specifics but
I don't think it was very happy either
so my point is is that look man at some
it's it's like that railing Givens quote
from Justified right if you wake up in
the morning you see an [__] hey man
you saw an [__] but if you wake up
you see an [__] at breakfast at lunch
and dinner every day you keep saying
[__] you're the [__] so you're
the [__] now I don't know if this was
you because apparently they've been
divorce since 2021 or getting the voice
since then what little I know right of
the family situation is that like the
the few times a few people have met his
wife absolutely lovely that's what I've
heard too is the like lovely person I've
heard that too
um so I mean unless I can't imagine
she's just this crazy person who's like
I can't take you anymore it just seems
like I'm not gonna say 100 I'm still a
woman the pattern is people leaving you
that's a good point so uh can we have
your Rumble plaque we'll get one okay
what do you mean you need a hundred
thousand
follow
uh I have been living with a proverbial
boot on my neck for going on years now
uh since 2021 I've been living through
what has increasingly been a horrendous
divorce now let me say now does this
maybe have something to do with
we was taking those months off he was
taking months off of the show he was
disappearing didn't recently his wife go
through something too like that that she
had some something happen to her yeah
yeah she was in my Hospital like she's
like for something bad actually an
infection or something remember
correctly the outset to be clear there
is no infidelity any kind of physical
abuse at all on either side
and no this was not
my choice my then wife decided that she
didn't want to be married anymore
and in the state of Texas that is
completely permitted it's permitted in
every state by the way Verizon I don't
mean like really his honor this we
watched a snippet of this it always
cracked me up earlier because that did
make me laugh he was like if that's I
mean it's pretty much legal in every
state you should I'm not allowed to just
keep them here's a hot tank you should
be allowed to get divorced I mean yeah
it happened you should have been quarter
you should have Incorporated louder or
Crowder in Dubai or somewhere where you
could have been like well she's legally
my property right have like a you know
we're like charade situation as I call
it um
it's been the most heartbreaking
experience of my life what I consider to
be my deepest personal failure and just
so you know my opinions on parenting and
families have not changed I've always
believed that children need a mom and a
dad that divorce is horrible okay can I
ask that question she's sitting on his
wife because apparently it's her idea so
now he's doing the he is [__] on our
low key but he's also I want to point
out then why did you hide it for two
years while still talking about it the
voice is bad because he gets there's two
reasons why
um I've reveled in this a little bit
this week because one
I [__] I [__] told us so all right
I predicted this [__] and then I [__]
even called it Friday and I said it's
official Friday and everybody was still
giving me [__] and then Monday it was
trending and I'm like come on number two
it's the it's the fact that you're a
hypocrite it's the fact that you're
disingenuous and the fact that you hid
your you you do this thing where you
pretend to be like you present yourself
like I'm an open guy man me my audience
with this connection man but really
you're full of [__] and you pretty much
hide everything in your personal your
professional life everything's under an
NDA everyone's signing a contract
everyone's shutting the [__] up and
that's weird bro so yeah when you start
going well yeah okay I should tell you
if the two years I've been rallying
against divorce and you know all this
[__] yeah I've been divorced what you
didn't expect is that the ROTC boys will
put a put a bug your your Rumble plaque
you didn't know that we have a
microphone in there we've been listening
for weeks we knew all about it we're
kidding by the way don't sue us we don't
actually have you tabbed I don't know
man he's super litigious I still believe
it I just wanna I just want to imagine a
world where a crowd is all [__] amped
up on Adderall and he's just looking all
around the [__] thing for like an
hour yeah get me that he probably owns
one all those bugs scanners bring me one
of those things I'm going to scan the
rumble put it outside until we scan it
and you know what's funny
daily wire plaque that he gave them an
appreciation award the whole time wasn't
even us it was daily wire breaks it and
it is a tiny daily wire plan inside of
it that says Jeremy on it
mom and a dad in that divorce is
horrible but in today's legal system
my beliefs don't matter
well in Texas divorce is permitted
why do you keep saying that in every
step
course has become too commonplace agreed
I think that marriage has become a
casual thing people jump into too easily
other than that right before it should
be legal like there are times where
you'd say what if you're [__] getting
beat up like I mean yeah what if they're
beating you and the kids and stuff you
know what if you just hate each other
like who cares really frankly
um yeah like what if somebody's about to
get a beating yeah you know you get to
that point where you're like I don't
think I can do this for 30 more years
you're not punching well there's holes
in the drywall and it's like all right
30 more years of this I'm going to hit
her in third in the next 30 years it's
going to happen statistically speaking
I'm only as strong as how much liquor
there's in the house oh she's gonna work
me up one day that's it um but yeah so I
don't know man you you are the [__]
problem as Royce stated yeah I mean this
guy is so wound up and control freak and
I can imagine he probably drove this
poor woman and again I know every time
we talk about crowded I know we're on
Rumble I know we're on his Turf you know
we're here first
um we we we know we know people are
going to [__] people people will support
him blindly because we're just from the
movement or this and that but the
problem is is that the one thing we said
at the beginning of the show there's
probably a lot of new people that that
are listening what voice of a show do
not make any of these people Heroes
especially us we [__] suck uh I'm
sorry correction especially us sorry I
apologize let me ask you a question all
right do you grade A morons not
understand no seriously though no but
we're here I'm following people we're
here to tell you to stop following we're
here to enter we're here to entertain
people we're here to make people laugh
hopefully like I said I've said this
before and I say it again Crowder
believes that these were these content
creators are going to save the world
content creators are the band playing in
the Titanic we're trying to entertain
people by the American experiment
[__] sinks to the bottom of the ocean
that's what I think I am that's all I've
ever wanted to do is [__] it make people
laugh that's all I ever want to do I
never wanted to [__] change the world
and everyone do anything crazy I think
Crowder thinks that he's doing that but
he's not you could defend him or not but
Crowder wants to be this person of this
ideal country but if this ideal country
was filled with control freaks like
Mercer said that were like Crowder if
they emulated him this country would
[__] suck it would be everybody
micromanaging everything counting every
threat in the [__] carpet throwing
shirts in people's faces and just
yelling at making people sign ndas
making no real friendship who's
Crowder's friends secretly Crowder's
friends secretly recording their
longtime friends
secretly recording something like
registering a website a month before
where he was going to already attacked
them right secretly recorded which I
don't care [__] Jeremy but the way he
treated producers the people that were
funnier than him anybody else that's
funnier than him he [__] he just he
doesn't like them around him that's what
really happens you could hate us [__]
dislike the video I don't give a [__]
but my point is is that we we've we've
been calling we called the shot years
ago like Babe Ruth and this is exactly
what happened this guy is not here for
anybody but himself you might find him
entertaining maybe you like really
terrible like if Weird Al was terrible
or whatever maybe that's what you're
into I don't even care that he's in this
for himself we should all be in this for
ourselves but but he's portraying it
like he's not it's my point yeah he
portrays it like he's not and it's not
just that he's selfish it's that he's a
petty spiteful
angry little control freak yeah who just
wants to be the king in the world and
everyone is one of his subjects right
and again like he said we call that shop
four years ago and we ate a lot of [__]
for it yeah so when you see us doing a
Victory lap of people go why are you
doing a Victory lap [__] you we are in a
Victory lap
around the base we got a lot of [__] and
now everyone's seeing what he really is
and he [__] exposes [__] belly
Like a Star Fox villain and not exactly
and now we know what your weak spot is
period wow it is by the way if the show
goes out or whatever I'm looking out
right now it is it's not nice I can hear
it is headphones on yeah even through
the headphones I'm here in the Wind
so for well over a year
uh well over a year in the best interest
as well as physical safety of my
children why are you out of breath
you've decided to keep this issue
private and to resolve as well as the
physical safety of my children I'm sorry
how would his children been have
compromised this is what we call oh I'm
sorry Royce this is what we call troll
shielding this is when uh somebody
immediately goes to leave my kids out of
this um but no one's even brought his
kids in it no I know but that's a troll
Shield that now the guys I don't think
anybody should [__] with his family I
we're 100 I think anybody is that's my
point yeah but like he's but here's the
thing right like uh uh the reason I
didn't post the screenshot uh earlier
yesterday because it was sent to me and
Trio logic ended up posting it sooner
remember yesterday when I was bitching
about drawing on [__] tiny pictures
yeah myself so I was trying to take his
kid's name out of the [__] screenshot
of the document so I could put it up and
then I got sidetracked and I never did
it triologic puts it up with the kids
names and stuff so even when I cover
[__] I don't bring kids into it I was
just pointing out hey this is the
document it says the divorce
um it's troll shielding it's it's what
everyone does remember when I said when
no one got mad because I said you know
someday if he keeps us up she's going to
take his kids and [__] leave them and
then he immediately went to he's
bringing my kids into it and I'm like no
I I was saying if you keep being an
[__] your wife's gonna take your kids
and leave that's not dragging your kids
into it that's not showing pictures of
your kids a dachshund no no so yeah he's
nobody's going after his kids this is a
troll Shield well over a year
uh well you're gonna have a 50 million
dollar contract if [__] Howard Stern
was getting diverse divorced from from
his wife it'd be all over the news and
everybody be talking about it like
Mercer sayings before the show goes
you're in the game this is how it is man
Mori Levy from The Wire you wanted to be
in the game now you're in the game
the difference between him and us is
that we're upfront pieces of [__] we've
told you from the beginning what we are
we're not [__] track conservatives
we've never been that we're a bunch of
[__] rock 2012 Ron Paul libertarian
guys that wanted to [__] Grill and
they didn't [__] leave us alone all
right like the quote Ron White we
weren't drunk in public we were drunk in
a bar you pushed us into public so here
we are but I mean we're not pretending
that we're virtuous or we're gonna save
anything or they're better than anybody
else that's just not what we are and I
think that's what makes me the most
upset about Crowder is that it'd be one
thing if he believed all those things
but also acted like it where you go you
know what say what you want about
Crowder but he lives it he lives it but
he's not he's mean to everybody around
him and by the way guys this isn't like
we have some sort of weird like we we
just doing this long enough we know
people that know people and we talk to
people and I'll tell you this there's
not a lot of good stories about people
who that have met him not many there's
not many good stories that you hear
about them there's there's not a lot of
great guys not a lot of yeah what a
great guy would have [__] cool dude
you don't really hear that there's other
people that we hear amazing stories
about the [__] awesome they're great
you know great great example of Alex
Jones is [__] as great as every story
that you've heard about him genuine guy
real dude but the difference between him
is he is what you see on the show
there's no Alex Jones off Fair must be
different he's not dude and Alex Jones
is despised by normies now yeah but
anybody that meets him I I was telling
the story I have friends with this woman
for years on Facebook and she's a real
Lefty like author hippie person like
totally from the other side of the aisle
I've known ever since the comedy days
and she met Alex Jones at some [__]
thing at some event and uh you know she
posted a picture and she had a couple
people go oh I'm blocking you like you
know I I can't I can't believe he would
do this but out of the few like other
people were like what's he like and like
all our replies are like he's the
[__] nicest guy like he's a lovely
guy you know I don't agree with him or
whatever but he you know so it's you
know again everybody meets Alex usually
he's like yeah I got kind of [__]
rules and there's like again other
people that people meet and they're like
Alex Stein is somebody most people yeah
I got [__] rules on your mind so it's
look man I used to think I was giving
this to crowded because people who you
jealous Crowders didn't [__] well
Crowder's dad's an amazing businessman
he he really is there you go 100 there
you go I'll give him that I'll give
credit his dad that he's an amazing
businessman he really knows how to sell
it he turned he turned basically a he he
turned a wait till [__] marriage God
damn comedian that's what he was got how
ironic is that he did away and he's a
marketing genius I mean you've been you
know convincing the right conservative
grift right that your son is straight
for like [__] what five six years now
which is we don't know we don't know if
he is or isn't I didn't say anything I
just said marketing he called himself
bisexual Mr Hyde now you called yourself
bisexual I've always been okay with it
over a year in the best interest as well
as physical safety of my children we've
decided to I mean this [__] Blair
white make you gay
I don't think so I think Blair white
[__] you makes you gay okay
keep this issue private and to resolve I
want to be clear I don't want to [__]
Blair white if it's all right
your dick getting sucked by Blair white
doesn't make you gay it makes you horny
and drunk but [__] Blair White's man
butt that makes you gay 100 you can't
get out of that that's fair all right
chat room survey says appropriate
attorneys they're gonna call this game
you're both gay I hate to I got news for
you that means you're gay gay
I have relationships with women and sex
with men
worst acting ever in that show I know
legal jargon and all this one thing I
want to be really clear about is certain
True North here is that
my children are blameless
completely without we know oh my God
he's doing it
nobody's bringing
in this man hey leave my kids out of it
yeah my kid Susie and Tommy leave them
out of it you're bringing them in I
broke the story [__] I broke the
screenshot too late last night because I
was specifically leaving your kids out
of it I was [__] trying to get the
goddamn names covered up at fault and so
we decided to resolve these issues
privately as it's in their best
interests both emotionally and
physically to do okay well here's the
unfortunate thing if you're a famous
person and you get divorced there's no
way to handle it your famous person when
you get divorced when you get divorced
there is no way to handle it privately
it's out there because you're famous
that's a really the only thing you can
keep from going out private is uh it
publicly is private matters if you can
both be [__] grown-ups the only two
people that have control over keeping it
Like A Private Matter look everyone's
going to know you're divorced and
everyone's gonna know you're a failed
dad and you're kidding that's fine your
kids aren't old enough to be to know
they're cute how old is the kids I don't
think his kids are like sitting there
watching watching our Channel while we
make fun of them like and that's not
what's Happening Here fun fact I heard
from a little birdie he wasn't even
there when they were born
um also like how much time was he
spending around them I mean to be fair
he had to change a lot of college kids
Minds that's why he couldn't be there a
lot of mine's getting changed huh so so
what I'm saying is what are you implying
how much how much are you saying that
there's hot college hunks how much do
you think he was around and now he wants
custody are you saying that sometimes
when some people not him but let's say
like some people go to colleges they
might notice some hot college hunks some
great American lacrosse studs maybe I
only go to college to change Minds
um I do to change air filters it was a
summer job Sony but only time I've been
to college
mid time I ever went to college was in
my early 20s and it was to sell Adderall
um
I went there to buy Adderall that's
[__] hilarious yeah
okay now the other issue is
and this is something that I've kept
private
for likely far too long
um
many other people knew about this
okay
behind the scenes okay
some not all but some of them in
positions of power
influence
Leverage
knew of this
they also knew that the safety of my
children included keeping it private so
if you're three familiar with the idea
of extortion
then you know the feeling well
uh now some of these Here Comes Here
Comes threats Here Comes we're so thinly
veiled that I'm frankly surprised you
didn't all guess immediately
Steven has a lot going on
best way to say it he has a lot going on
and that should be clear because people
don't do stuff like this if there's not
a lot going on in their lives I would
like to implore my audience and
everybody that isn't paying attention
this situation not to condemn him but to
pray for him sometimes people need a
prayer sometimes people need a scripture
you know Stephen purports to be a
Christian I am unsure at this moment if
it is my place to say more than that
I'll be honest with you here she's a
piece of [__] right that being said I
don't know if that's legally extortion
because she never actually said anything
now this is okay now I'm going to play a
little bit we're not done with the video
but Canada did tweet this out I got the
tweet
um Stephen Crowder accusing me of
extortion is so patently insane that it
honestly makes me question how there are
still people who cannot see how
thoroughly undone he has become now this
is not the stable Behavior he is the man
on a spiral outright bizarre and
concerning so hey remember when they
were friends I remember we told you it
was going to happen you guys said we
were wrong and stupid well we're only
one of those things
how's that I'm happy does that feel
stupid
um
look man
even the black and disowns folks extort
and uh wonderful Stephen Crowder we love
Stephen Crowder I've been divorced
before Pilots okay I got tons of kids
tons of wives I heard giving my lawyer
just get a similar mug somehow kid
um Crowder University and Crowder Stakes
coming soon she would do it too he'd go
right into that
um yeah she is low-key extorting him
here because this is when daily wire was
fighting whenever she started doing that
yeah it'd be a real shame if everybody
started reporting on that [__] 24 7. she
is low-key kind of doing that but she's
not wrong Steven is also in a spiral so
I love it I love watching these things
[__] at each other Stephen welcome to
the mud pit kids
Stephen my Stephen might be in a [__]
spot which he is Steven Steven is in a
[__] spiral but that be that being
said I mean Steve is basic Stephen
Crowder is basically
complaining that she's doing to him
something that he's done to a bunch of
people something that that's all he does
to people Stephen Crowder has made a
career about going after people and
releasing stuff and look look at this
Stephen Crowder is talking about
explosion Stephen Crowder is talking
about extortion oh God
he recorded Jeremy phone call this is
actually this extortion started with
extortion yeah so it's like the
Spider-Man pointing at each other thing
is what's going on like Stephen Crowder
buddy you're the one who recorded a
conversation and then played it on air
what do you call that you can't be mad
at snakes for being snakes but you're
one too to quote the girl I'm not
defending Canada's owns by the way
Candace Owens used to [__] run a
doxing website so to quote The Lovable
Kevin Brennan yeah I started it because
he started it
he literally said that about giving out
phone numbers because he gave out my
call to his number Mike Calta gave out
his number and they were like well you
did start this and
that that fits this city that is
literally fits Stephen Crowder's
Insanity yeah I started it because he
started it it's like nobody can do any
clubs
that's [__] gay
maybe if I feel in further defense
something should be said or maybe if I
feel that the public has a right to
understand certain circumstances but
Crowder is ignoring is that he was
taking shots at her too so it's not like
Crowder was his innocent little boy
he is kind of picking this is like I
love that you're all fighting oh it's
delicious
not only
are they all fighting but right now the
one with the most enemies and who's like
the weak is crowded Crowders is getting
[__] Crowders like Germany in 1944
they're just like you know what we're
breaking all trees we're fighting
everybody at once and you're like well
this is a terrible idea sir I feel like
we're gonna lose
so this is so uh so doesn't it feel good
it feels so good hey can somebody
Photoshop Stephen Crowder at the end of
a Scarface yeah when he's got like the
machine gun on the desk and the pile of
blow and just change it to like orange
powder and put like and put like a
couple empty Adderall bottles like
Photoshop them hanging around there so
they're crushed up just change the light
to Orange you're also
oh my children have a right to privacy
wow say it again well then you should
quit don't my children have a right to
privacy says the man who recorded a
contract negotiation with his friends
and then aired it on a station and also
posted pictures with his children on his
social media when it was appropriate to
do that yeah to Garner more mugs because
oh he's a family man so you can use your
kids as a [__] as a mug selling
tactic but then you want to Shield them
when the bad times come if you want your
kids to have a private quiet life
[__] retire them's the rules all
right them's the rules
now some other uh issues have been or I
should say uh
inferences have been more pernicious
behind this is there an airplane flying
over his Studio it sounds like he's put
he's broadcasting with virgie's house
scenes with demands and threats to use
this information that they believe would
be so publicly embarrassing to me and my
wife in a difficult time oh no everyone
should be nice to the guy who's a
[__] piece of [__] to everybody
around him and treats people like
garbage everyone be nice to him also
don't give guys like this ammo ever see
be like me just [__] find [__] out
the stupidest thing you could ever do in
life even if you don't think you're
extorting somebody or is going to
somebody that you have info on and then
bragging to them that you have info even
if you're just bragging it could be
conceived as extortion do what I do just
go oh is this confirmed can we
corroborate this hey by the way this
guy's [__] said he was bisexual and
he's [__] divorced you know what I
mean like you I'm just telling you what
the facts are once they're [__]
proven you go hey here you go boys just
live in the sunshine you know just tell
people you know when people are bad
seems to be the good way to go right it
could be used knowingly putting my
children In Harm's Way so to those
self-styled Christians conservatives and
allies
well not in my book
now if you find yourself I don't want to
get into details so this is going to
likely be the only time I have to
address this or want to address this if
you're asking yourself hey did X person
or did y person know the answer is
likely yes
but he immersion Royce
um when he you think he's you know what
I love more than anything
they just pan over I don't know he's not
there but it would just be hilarious to
the other chair and Brewers just they're
like
is it Brewer though because I'm hearing
Brewer said no now Bruce is coming out
every once in a while yeah it's Apollo
right I don't know I don't know I don't
here's the thing I don't know if you
know this I don't want your show well I
heard Apollo like had a moment where he
cursed and he apologized on the air so
that's already going well
you can't curse on crowder show for real
I mean that's kind of a [__]
no I mean no bisexual but you're not
allowed like I didn't know that I'm not
being serious I don't get why maybe he's
allowed but only when he you know only
when the moment moves yes which will be
made a lot of telling Nick the Apollo
not the curse Jesus Christ good luck
yeah it's almost like these uh you know
freaking liberals they're you know out
there doing
stuff being a bunch of Mary's
armingly clear as this process of
discovery continues uh and it also by
the way makes me that much more
appreciative of those who did know about
this and in understanding the best
interests of my family my children kept
their word and used discretion
no no they told people behind your back
Crowder how do you think everyone knew
but hold on yeah come on man Crowder
they all talk [__] just you didn't find
out you shouldn't find out
I can't thank you enough sincerely I
appreciate it won't forget it it's it's
pretty simple I
loved a woman so much that I married her
a woman who despite all of this I still
love as
the mother of my children
and she wanted something else for her
life was it a black trainer I'm just
trying to understand a straight man
that's not my choice
she simply wanted out and the law says
the law says I gotta let her go
saying it like the law shouldn't say
that can I ask I'm understanding here
I'm trying to get this can I can I ask a
question Roy sure let's say that the law
there wasn't any divorce laws right okay
there's just really no law regarding
divorce or any kind of custody or
anything you're just you guys are
married and she just wanted to leave
right
to what extent would you stop
you know what I mean like look I
understand look as a man Royce I'm sure
you as a man understand
we've all blocked the doorway once or
twice in our lives right and then
there's there's a level of decency of
how long you can block a doorway you got
about 20 seconds come on come on let's
you know beyond that Steve Beyond
jumping in front of a doorway and going
come on what are you gonna really do
this
how far are we breaking out the Sig
Sauer are we like what are we doing if
it's you if it's Steve makes the rules I
mean because it sounds pretty weird that
as Royce pointed out he said he said
like like two or four times two or three
times but like six or seven times you do
like holding women captive Crowder yeah
I mean I mean like what do we want
Sharia law here
here let me show you I actually I
actually I don't know if this is true so
obviously please guys do not I'm just
not legally responsible but I think that
this is video this is security camera
footage of what he does when she tried
to leave this is him
this is what he does
is still half empty [__]
[Music]
now you just can't leave
I will never forget oh no Jesus a
Crowder Trail hey can somebody put the
producer's face Bob Schneider was in
this movie that's not rob you can't do
it usually you can do it biker
from the Bronxville
you're confusing movies oh I'm sorry
Walther goofy boots he carries a Walther
eye of a sick I apologize so yeah you
break out the Walther and start chasing
her out I look as somebody who I have
been really mean to women I don't what I
know I don't even think they should vote
and that's not
uh so my opinion of women is obviously
well known
Crowder I think you might even be more
based than I am because yeah like I'm
getting real if the laws weren't the
laws you'd be a captive type vibes from
you we should be changed to a [__]
heater like it was a black snake mode
exactly oddly enough Owen Benjamin's EX
the whole thing's connected
Infowars we're [__] doing it
um hold on a little bit more we have we
do have to definitely finish it because
every second of this video is fairy
telling that's how it works now of
course look I get it there are multiple
sides to every story but one thing that
is undeniable uh is that everyone and
everyone in my purview signed an NDA I'm
sorry the salty engineering chat I
wonder what kind of NDA the kids had
come on man it's just just the idea of
hitting crayon so soulless by the way
that little joke right there like
knowing him will be like see they are
coming after my kids that's a joke
Stephen no one's actually doing it Steve
let me explain comedy to you because you
don't get comedy see the joke is so
funny because she's such a tight ass
you're such a tight ass control freak
lunatic that it would be funny for
instance if you like let's say through a
birthday party for your kid at a skating
rink and they didn't like their presents
and you made them sign an NDA that if
they ever told anyone that they were
disappointed in their presence that you
would sue the [__] out of them that's
funny Steve prenup you think they sign a
prenup probably I'm trying I'm wondering
now dad's in charge yeah
look I get it there are multiple sides
to every story but one thing that is
undeniable uh in this case that it's no
one's fault but my own
in that I picked wrong and that's
what a passive could you hear oh my God
wow you're worried about your children
and you're talking about their mother
that way this feels what no he's gonna
browbeat you if you buy privacy I'm the
mother of my children
that statement bro you okay I'm gonna
play it again let's everyone bask in
this but one thing that is undeniable
yeah that's no one's fault but my own
I'm basking in this in that I picked
wrong and that's certainly not the fault
of my children I am
bash I picked wrong dad mommy what did
Daddy mean when he said he picked wrong
is there something wrong with you how
she shielded himself for the children
and then he used him as a cuddled at the
end this is the beginning of the end
I picked wrong I am
basking in this
I am I did it already Marsha I did I did
the the face you wipe your hands down
your face and you just you you take it
in
I am basking in this it's the best do
you he just sat there and you just
immersed moist look I feel bad for those
kids and of course and nobody I I don't
know how does your dad
but when for you have to understand guys
this is like for
for we we took
so much [__] for this for years for
calling them out in the beginning and
everyone going you guys are full of [__]
you guys [__] suck I Can't Believe
It's Not punching right and now it's
just sorry man gotta do a goddamn
Victory lap on this holy [__] can I play
that one more I need a picture he's a
psychopath I need to play one more time
the Canadian psycho he just accused
everybody of what of what he just did
but that's how it works now of course
look I get it there are multiple sides
to every story but one thing that is
undeniable is that she's not legally
allowed to tell her but my own
in that I picked wrong and that's
certainly not the fault of my children
and I will say that what's in the best
interest of my children um is not
internet drama speculation
certainly not blatant or failed
shakedowns or dragging their father or
mother and I can't be clear on them you
just dropped
you just did it
he just did it I made the mistake of
picking wrong he know what he did he
knows what he's doing dude
dude dude
you
this video first of all can I break down
a couple of the last things he just did
there one
thank you for that
thank you
that was deeper uh that is very well
done taper I love it [__] Adderall
[__] he's ready to go down he's
[__] ready to fight Sosa don't sue us
um
dude I all right one thing now I got him
I lost my train of thought sorry those
are the devs oh and the great great
Photoshop and the Adderall what he just
did at the end there was for one he just
chased off another piece of his audience
people are gonna go
ew dude the [__] uh number two like he's
still gonna make tons of [__] shitloads
of money he's always gonna have [__]
tons of people watching him but he's
gonna lose a couple of his real loyal
like you know people that actually pay
they're gonna go this is kind of gross
um I got divorced and I don't remember
speaking about my wife this way uh the
other problem you just did here
if you're oh now ex-wife did
theoretically sign some sort of an NDA
or uh some sort of prenup right yeah
you going live on your show and making
statements like uh daddy picked wrong I
still love my kids but she broke up with
me and she's she was you know terrible
person you may have a good lawyer might
get with your wife and say you know you
actually now have a case to invalidate
the NDA and that would make him
financially [__] you know really
really wanting to maybe make peace with
you again I'm just saying if I'm you I
go to a lawyer and I go hey he made me
sign in theoretically if you made him
sign an NDA he made me sign a thing
saying in my case oh this [__] who's
richer than me she made me sign all this
[__] right then whatever marriage didn't
work out whatever and then she made me
sign this huge NDA whatever but then she
goes on our show and she's telling
everybody I'm a piece of [__] and I
[__] you know you know I'm sorry to
my kids and my kids alone
like I'm not defending her maybe she is
terrible but my point is is that maybe
she's terrible but then like Merced go
all in and say she's horrible but don't
sit there and go I want people to be
nice that's the mother of my children
and then take a passive aggressive
[__] shot on your show about her and
that lean in me made this one nice so
that's the thing when we have awesome
fans we got both I just think you can um
you can see sort of like
an opportunity there where it's like I
think in most cases now I don't think
can you
I don't think that you're allowed like I
don't think I'm allowed to make you
think you're allowed to do that yeah man
was it uh it's not fair it's not it's
not being fair no but I don't think for
instance right like if you made me sign
in NDA and then you just went on day
wave and started talking Cash Money [__]
about some specific weekend you made me
sign in NDA about yeah starting to
whatever you immediately invalidate the
NDA right in most jurisdictions nowadays
you can't do that yeah I can't make you
I can't [__] Muzzle you and then go
on the news and be like yeah by the way
Royce is a pedophile wait what hey you
signed in NDA you're not allowed to talk
about me in any context ever like that
would immediately make a judge go we're
throwing this out you're obviously
abusing the [__] system so you might
got open you might got an open shot here
since he wanted to run his mouth
yeah I mean uh somebody said Royce is a
sent me he's got to be kidding male
feminist talking about relation yeah
because that's us if you listen to our
show women love us which are so nice to
them all the time I believe they're all
liars I believe all women when they're
attacking other women I don't think
women have ever been raped ever how's
that I'm going the full the other way
ever all women all rapes her lies yeah
unfortunately rape laws are a thing in
the State of Florida I don't see me put
in the States
but he did it you're protecting your
children look all I'm saying is this
[__] apparently your wife can have
kids with you and then decide that she
doesn't want to be there anymore and
take the kid to the in-laws house and
the State of Florida allows it I can't
just grab her by the neck and stick a
gun in her face and say yeah
like Stephen we all want to be able to
do that we're with you pal but I
wouldn't say that on your show
this is one of those like any scenario
you think of where people joke about
like you know the law versus morally not
doing something and then when people
will talk about a certain law sometimes
and you're like wait so the law was
stopping you from doing that or you know
what I mean like I thought you just
didn't do that because it was wrong yeah
it's like people that it's like the
people that rely on age of consent
you know it's like why are you flying
that low with the [__] plane anyway
are you trying to like hide radar or
something oh they want to just want to
be on if I want a tick tock account I
think's the reason why or also Grindr I
mean let's go down the [__] list bro
uh um or their mother through the mud
and to anyone who tries it
like I'm no longer going to pacify
capitulate or sidestep because I love
them a whole lot more than I love you
and I will continue to do whatever is
necessary to protect my children
discussing a divorce any further on
social media or on this show or in any
public space it's not what's best for
them
I'll be handling this through the proper
legal Avenues and channels available as
a matter of record in which I have more
than full confidence
so I'd ask how you understand the need
for and uh so if we talk about your
divorce you're going to sue us is that
what you're saying Crowder
because I mean maybe I misunderstanding
what he just said because nothing's
going to make me want to talk about your
divorce more
then you threatening me Sue me talking
about your divorce
is is is is that what he's saying
it's I believe he's implying it right
no we're going to talk about your stupid
divorce stupid I can't do what I want
and then I got you know he kind of does
what he wants we can't even always agree
on what to do like I can't I never know
what I'm waking up to the night Smurfs
drinks I have no [__] clue [__] no
clue it's crazy then he's got to deal
with that I gotta deal with his Neurosis
30 fights a day it's what you're talking
about whatever but at the end of the day
we come in primed we've been sparring
all day by the time we got to deal with
you [__] it's nothing this is
[__] nothing we're training you
understand we're in the heart dungeon
every day this is nothing for us okay
I'm at Norton I'm coming into work I got
blood coming out of my mouth and a black
eye and I'm not [__] and I'm [__]
David Arquette I'm not getting called
WWE because they didn't like the Nick
Gage cutting my head with a pizza cutter
thing you saw this Jericho no no no no
no no no no Arquette also did that and
WWE was gonna let him have his big
comeback match here there's a throwback
little gimmick but because he did he
also did a match with Nick Gage and he
also did the pizza cutter bit and that's
the thing that cart gets like look don't
[__] with my face do not [__] with my
face I'm an actor please don't Nick
Gibson anyway WWE because of that Matt
said he can't be on hear me out David
Arquette you go to aw you win the aw
title
two-time World Champ that's worthless
respect our privacy if you see the new
gold belt looks like trash too
what is obviously and what did uh Escape
Polly call it the Ring of Honor TNT
title yeah what you should call it